we've got to get through this town hall
if you didn't watch it I recommend you
watch the whole thing it was absolutely
delightful it was delightful largely
because Trump totally owned the libs
with facts and logic and it was it was
just
marvelous to watch you kind of felt like
you had that old energy back again right
but the reason that I want to cover it
and I'll I'll try to do it relatively
quickly I want to hit on Five Points
because I think that the Trump Town Hall
appearance Beyond delighting everybody
with Trump's zingers showed us five
important things about his 2024 campaign
first one is
Trump is going to bring receipts they
were breaking into the capital smashing
Windows injuring police officers why did
you why did it take you three hours to
tell them to go home I don't believe it
did oh let me pull it out
so
so if you look at
on January 5th the day before I said
please support our Capitol Police and
law enforcement they are truly on the
side of our country stay peaceful stay
peaceful this was the day before and
this was in the form of Twitter now use
truth truth social I think it's far
superior okay I hope everybody's like I
hope everybody's on truth if you look
January 6th of two before 2 30. I am
asking for everyone at the U.S Capitol
to remain peaceful this is right after
as it was happening but what happened is
they took it down I don't know why I
think they took it down because it was
so good they didn't like it being up
there I am asking this is and we didn't
know until I got it back because now I
have 90 million people waiting for me to
go back but I'm on truth and I'm staying
on truth you didn't say anything for 700
hours after actually I did boom and he
just pulls out that sheet of paper this
was in a way an answer to that Infamous
incident between Mitt Romney and Barack
Obama and Candy Crowley the moderator I
think also from CNN back in 2012 when
Mitt Romney said you didn't call the
Benghazi terror attack a terror attack
until long after the attack and Candy
Crowley intervened on Barack Obama's
behave and said actually he did Governor
he did and then it turned out she was
just making that up that wasn't true
this was kind of the opposite where you
had the moderator or the hostess Caitlin
Collins
she says you didn't talk about this for
hours and hours and Trump says I got my
own receipts here we go uh good to know
that it's good to know that Trump is
going to have the facts at his
fingertips when you hear all of these
kinds of charges that are inevitably
going to come up throughout the 2024
campaign next thing it showed us is that
Trump is
thoughtful Trump is thinking in a
nuanced way about major political issues
notably foreign policy
do you want Ukraine to win this War uh I
don't think in terms of winning and
losing I think in terms of getting it
settled so we stop killing all these
people and breaking them
[Applause]
can I just follow up on that and you
said you don't think you have to do is
follow up on that because that's a
really important excuse me
can you say if you want Ukraine or
Russia to win this War I want everybody
to stop dying they're dying Russians and
ukrainians I wanted to stop dying and
I'll have that done I'll have that done
in 24 hours I'll have it done you need
the power of the presidency to do it but
you won't say that you want Ukraine to
win you you know what I'll say I'll say
this I want Europe to put up more money
because they're in for 20 billion we're
in for 170 and they shouldn't answered
and they should equalize they have
plenty of money they should equalize
this is a very thoughtful answer on
Ukraine the liberal view on Ukraine is
rah-rah World War III let's start
dropping bombs on Moscow let's go after
the Kremlin let's assassinate Putin
forget about just chasing Russian
influence out of Ukraine we want Ukraine
to go in and let's have them invade
Russia let's let's go oh baby NATO on
the Move that's the liberal View
the conservative view is a little more
restrained than that it's a little bit
more conservative the conservative view
is the view that has been articulated by
Statesmen going back 30 years now by
George Kennan author of The Long
Telegram by people like Henry Kissinger
by people like Daniel Patrick Moynihan
and Sam Nunn people who said you know
we've got to be a little bit careful
about how NATO expands and actually
buffer States aren't the worst thing in
the world because they they mediate
between great powers and so what are we
going to do here in Ukraine are we
really going to Route Russia we're going
to call for regime change in Russia what
are we going to do we're going to get
Russia out of Crimea what are we going
to do we're going to invite Ukraine to
join NATO what is that really going to
de-escalate this situation or no is that
going to send us hurtling toward World
War III well you've got China aggressing
in Taiwan and the South China Sea that
doesn't seem to make sense and so so
Trump knows this Trump knows that if he
says I want Ukraine to win first of all
you're going to just be affirming what
Russia's already said which is that the
U.S is a belligerent in the Ukraine war
and the us is not just waging a kind of
cold war here that the U.S is waging a
hot war with Russia you're only going to
escalate that which is what all the
Liberals and the Hawks are doing on this
particular issue and Trump says no I
just want to wind down the conflict
which a lot of wise Statesmen think the
United States could do if it felt that
it were in its interest to wind down the
conflict so really nuanced answer here
from Trump not just a total Dove not
just a total Hawk he's giving a
thoughtful answer right now go to
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show let
me ask you something when you use the
restroom you always close the door
behind you right you don't want random
passers-by looking in on you so why
would you let people look in on you when
you go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the restroom and not
closing the door okay I love expressvpn
I'm a total Luddite so I barely know how
to use any technology but it's so easy
to use even I can use it you just
download it one click of a button on
your cell phone on your laptop on your
on your iPad on whatever you want I can
say with full confidence expressvpn is
the best VPN on the market here's why
number one expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can stream HD videos with
zero buffering number three expressvpn
is incredibly easy to use
it's that one button you're done you're
good to go if you're like me you believe
your online activity is your business
use our link expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show today get three months free
in a one-year package
expresvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show the
next thing we learned about Trump is
that the guy is still super funny
I never met this woman I never saw this
woman this woman said I met her at the
front door of Bergdorf Goodwin which I
rarely go into other than for a couple
of charities
I met her in the front door she was
about 60 years old and this is like 22
23 years ago I met her in the front door
of Bergdorf Goodman I was immediately
attracted to her she was immediately
attracted to me and we had this great
chemistry we're walking into a crowded
department so we had this great
chemistry and a few minutes later we end
up in a a room a dressing room a book of
Goodman right near the cash register and
then she found out there locks in the
door she said I found one that was open
she found one she learned this at trial
she found one that was open what kind of
a woman meets somebody and brings them
up and within minutes you're playing
hanky-panky in a dressing room okay I
don't know if she was married then or
not John Johnson I feel sorry for you
John Mr President can I no but think of
it they said he didn't rape her and they
didn't I didn't do anything else either
you know what because I have no idea who
the hell she is
can I ask you given your recounting I
don't know who and and I tell you this
but Mr President are you ready can I can
I swear on my children which I never do
I have no idea who this one this is a
fake Story made up story so it's really
funny I because we could only put a
short clip in there you might lose a
little bit of the context that when he's
recounting that tale at the beginning
he's saying this is her version of
events I walk into Bergdorf Goodman
which I pretty much never did I'm in a
crowded department store and then the
whole rest of it reads like a romance
novel and that last part I think is
important too because Trump obviously
has engaged in hyperbole exaggeration
let's say a little bending of the truth
every now and again and he was a
billionaire playboy for a long time but
at the end there when he says listen to
me I swear on my children and I never do
that I have no idea who this woman is I
this did not happen
one feels that that is sincere one has
the impression that that is sincere and
he's funny the whole time it's the only
way to deflate this they're accusing him
of the worst things you can be accused
of
they're accusing him of rape okay
they're acute and he's saying either you
say no I didn't do it kind of like when
when someone wants to set you up they
say hey do you still beat your wife
and any way you answer you you look bad
and so what does he do he just makes fun
of the whole situation of this romance
novel situation that that appeared on an
episode of Law and Order SVU seven years
before the woman published her claims he
mocks it he hits you with sincerity it's
very
persuasive on the campaign Trail and
then the final point
that we learned from the CNN town hall
and this is the most important thing I
think for the Trump campaign to convey
to the GOP base is that Trump this go
round at least
intends to be disciplined
you still have not publicly acknowledged
the 2020 election results why should
Americans put you back in the white
house because we did fantastically we
got 12 million more votes than we had in
as you know in 2016. I actually say we
did far better in that election got the
most uh that anybody's ever gotten as is
the president of the United States uh I
think that when you look at that result
and when you look at what happened
during that election unless you're a
very stupid person you see what happens
a lot of the people a lot of the people
in this audience and maybe a couple that
don't but most people understand what
happened that was a rigged election and
it's a shame that we had to go through
it it's very bad for our country all
over the world they looked at it this
back to what you just said there though
it was not a rigged election it was not
a stolen election you and your
supporters lost more than 60 court cases
on the election it's been nearly two and
a half years can you publicly
acknowledge that you did lose the 2020
election let me just go on if you look
at through the vote they found millions
of votes on camera on government cameras
where they were suffering ballot boxes
there's even more too we had to we had
to cut the clip to keep it a little a
little tighter for the show
Trump at that first debate with Joe
Biden would never have allowed that
woman to get her nonsense interjection
in there Mr President actually fact
check you lost you lost the election was
not rigged it was totally the most Fair
wonderful beep boop election in beep
beep boop there were no questions about
and had this been
the the first debate of 2020 had this
been a less disciplined campaign Trump
would have come in and gotten into a
shouting match with her going back and
forth he exhibited incredible restraint
there in fact he exhibited more
restraint than I just exhibited even
listening to what she had to say and
there was no question in my mind that
that was intentional and it's to convey
to the GOP base that this campaign is
going to be disciplined
the most important line of the night
most important line of the ninth
did not come during the town hall the
most important line of the night and
probably the line that bodes best for
Trump's campaign came before the town
hall when Trump announced it
I'll be doing CNN tonight live from the
great state of New Hampshire because
CNN is rightfully desperate to get those
fantastic Trump ratings back
they were ratings like none other and
they want them back so sitting with
sweet little Alisa last night we were
listening to to the town hall and Elisa
said to me she goes seriously though why
why did CNN agree to do this town hall
and then just before I could answer she
answered it herself she goes is it
literally just because they want those
fantastic Trump ratings and the answer
is yes and this is why Trump is going to
get all that free media he got billions
of dollars worth of free media in 2016.
this is why CNN is going to have him
back on this is why they're all going to
have him back on this is why his poll
numbers are going up because you can't
look away you might say well other
political candidates they've proven
themselves to be more effective at
wielding power or more nuanced about
policy or maybe that's true I'm not even
going to weigh in there I'm just telling
you
this guy is a singular political Talent
he's an American original his worst
aspects are American original his best
aspects are American original okay
there's no copy of him did you adore
that clip me too if you want to get more
of them if you want to get long
interviews if you want to get the yes or
no game if you want Michael and if you
want The Daily Show subscribe right here
ring that Bell we'll see you next time